So the first successful
pitch meeting was very cool.
We made a lot of progress.
We had terms set up and we decided
that we were going to meet again and
going to bring my co-founders and
we're going to sign term sheet,
and I came to that
meeting like a winner.
Hey, I'm here.
Where's the money?
Those are the co-founders,
let's get on with it.
And the investor looked at me and said,
Norm, I'm not in your pocket, you know.
I think that you're going to get
three or four more investors
that will commit the same amount
of money, and then we'll proceed.
I don't know any more investors.
I just got introduced to you by
someone that I'm working with.
But we did, we did that.
We went and brought more investors
to participate in the same round and
he eventually gave me the money and
he became one of my dearest friends and
that was the story of
the first investor.